[Music]
Janet Jackson's estranged husband with
samal mana spotted out amid their split
and only et has the exclusive pics there
actually has been a sudden change I
thought it was important that you'd be
the first to know and I witnessed lzt
shortly after the birth of her son eisah
in January the superstar checked out a
few upscale residences in the Mayfair
area of London then just before
Valentine's Day Janet and her personal
assistant were seen apartment hunting
again it's believed the singer was
possibly searching for a new home to
share with her son in the beginning of
March the eyewitness noticed that
Janet's assistant who frequently visited
the couple's home stopped coming by and
Janet hasn't been spotted at the London
residence in several weeks
fast-forward to Friday here's Wisam
looking casual outside his home the
Qatari billionaire received several baby
items including bags of toys and a
massive balloon display the eyewitness
explained quote the baby was seen
leaving with sums property the next day
at around lunchtime in a car seat with a
white blanket covering him with a staff
member present Janet was not seen the
eyewitness believes Janet is currently
living nearby
perhaps just minutes from the home she
shared with her ex
[Music]
you